what do we make of conspiracy theories
the phrase itself is
pushing you in a direction right so so
clearly in history there we've had many
large coordinated keepings of secrets
right say the manhattan project right
and there was a lot of hundreds of
thousands of people working on that over
many years but they they kept it a
secret right clearly many large military
operations have kept things secrets over
you know even decades
with many thousands of people involved
so clearly it's possible to keep
something secret over time periods
um
you know but the more people you involve
and the more time you're assuming and
the more the less centralized
organization or the less discipline they
have the harder it gets to believe but
we're just trying to calibrate basically
in our minds
which kind of secrets can be kept by
which groups over what time periods for
what purposes right but let me uh i
don't have enough data so i'm somebody
i you know i hang out with people and i
love people i love all things really and
i just
i think that most people even the
[ __ ] have the capacity to be good
and they're beautiful and i enjoy them
so the kind of data my brain whatever
the chemistry of my brain is that sees
the beautiful and things
is maybe collecting a subset of data
that doesn't allow me to intuit
the competence
that humans are able to uh to uh
achieve
in uh constructing a conspiracy theory
so for example one one thing that people
often talk about is like intelligence
agencies this like broad thing they say
the cia the fsb the different the
british intelligence i've uh fortunate
or unfortunate enough never gotten a
chance that i know of to talk to any
member of those intelligence agencies uh
nor
like
uh take a peek behind the curtain or the
first curtain i don't know how many
levels of curtains there are and so i
don't i can't intuit but my interaction
with this government i
was funded by dod and darpa and i've
interacted uh been to the pentagon
like
with all due respect
to my friends lovely friends and
government and there are a lot of
incredible people but there is a very
giant bureaucracy that sometimes
suffocates the ingenuity of the human
spirit is one way i can put it meaning
they are i just it's difficult for me to
imagine extreme competence at a scale of
hundreds or thousands human beings now
that doesn't mean that's my very
anecdotal data of the situation and so i
try to build up my intuition
about
centralized system of government
how much conspiracy is possible how much
the intelligence agencies or some other
source can
generate
sufficiently robust propaganda that
controls the populace if you look at
world war ii as you mentioned there have
been extremely powerful propaganda
machines on the nazi on the side of nazi
germany on the side of the soviet union
on the side of the united states and all
these different
uh
mechanisms sometimes they control the
free press
through social pressures sometimes they
control the press
through
the threat of violence you know as you
do in authoritarian regimes sometimes
it's like deliberately the dictator like
writing the news
the headlines and literally announcing
it and uh
something about
human psychology forces you
to uh
to embrace the narrative and believe the
narrative and at scale that becomes
reality when the initial spark
was just the propaganda thought in a
single individual's mind so i don't i
can't necessarily intuit
of what's possible but i'm
skeptical
of the power of human institutions to
construct
uh conspiracy theories that cause
suffering at scale especially in this
modern age when information is becoming
more and more accessible by the populace
anyway that's
i don't know if you can
elucidate suffering at scale but of
course say during wartime the people who
are managing the various conspiracies
like d-day or manhattan projects they
thought that their conspiracy was
avoiding harm rather than causing harm
so if you can get a lot of people to
think that supporting the comparison
conspiracy is helpful then a lot more
might do that and there's just a lot of
things that people just don't want to
see
so if you can make your conspiracy the
sort of thing that people wouldn't want
to talk about anyway even if they knew
about it
you're you know most of the way there so
i have learned many over the years many
things that most ordinary people should
be interested in but somehow don't know
even though the data has been very
widespread so you know i have this book
the elephant in the brain and one of the
chapters is there on medicine and
basically
most people seem ignorant of the very
basic fact that when we do randomized
trials where we give some people more
medicine than others
the people who get more medicine are not
healthier
just overall in general just like induce
somebody to get more medicine because
you just give them more budget to buy
medicine say
not not a specific medicine just the
whole category
and you would think that would be
something most people should know about
medicine you you might even think that
would be a conspiracy theory to think
that would be hidden but in fact most
people never learn that fact so just to
clarify
just a general high level statement the
more medicine you take the less healthy
you are
randomized experiments don't find that
fact
do not find that more medicine makes you
more healthy yeah they're just no
connection
oh in randomized experiments there's no
relationship between more medicine so
it's not a negative relationship but
it's just no relationship right
uh and uh so the the
the conspiracy theory is b would say
that the businesses that sell you
medicine don't want you to know that
fact and then you're saying that there's
also part of this
is that people just don't want to know
they just don't want to know and so they
don't learn this so you know i've lived
in the washington area for several
decades now reading the washington post
regularly every week there was a special
you know
section on health and medicine it never
was mentioned in that section of the
paper in all the 20 years i read that
so do you think there is some truth to
this caricatured blue pill red pill
where most people don't want to know the
truth not
many things about which people don't
want to know certain kinds of truths
yeah that is bad looking truths truths
that
discouraging truths that sort of take
away the justification for things they
feel passionate about
do you think that's
a bad aspect of human nature that's
something we should try to overcome
um well as we discussed my first
priority is to just tell people about it
to do the analysis and the cold facts of
what's actually happening and then to
try to be careful about how we can
improve so our book the elephant in the
brain co-authored with kevin simler is
about hidden motives in everyday life
and our first priority there is just to
explain to you what are the things that
you are not looking at that you have
reluctant to look at
and many people try to take that book as
a self-help book where they're trying to
improve themselves and and make sure
they look at more things and that often
goes badly because it's harder to
actually do that than you think
yeah and so but we at least want you to
know that that this truth is available
if you want to learn about it it's the
nietzsche if you gaze longer to the
abyss the abyss gazes into you
you